thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story The near 20 increase in
the cost of food serving up an
unpleasant helping of higher inflation
economists say interest rates will now
rise to hitting many mortgage holders as
the bank of England tries to squeeze
price pressure out of the economy
also tonight counting the cost of the s
p crisis the party's Treasurer resigns
as a senior figure admits its culture
could be to blame
feeling the hand of history back on
their shoulders the leaders trying to
re-energize Northern Ireland politics 25
years on
President Putin's mercenary Army accused
of the vilest of crimes but denying that
orders were given for the deliberate
killing of children
and running into the record books for
the wrong reasons the ultra marathon
athlete disqualified after she went part
of the route by car
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's coming up
in our press preview from 10 30.
[Music]
hello there good evening in America it's
half of the rate here even in the
Eurozone it's significantly less the
latest inflation figures showed that
price Rises are proving stubbornly high
in the UK and it's likely to mean more
mortgage paying for many homeowners well
inflation actually fell in the year to
march to 10.1 percent but that slight
drop was much less than anticipated that
was partly because food inflation went
up again to a 45-year high of 19.1
percent that means that interest rates
which just weeks ago were thought to
have peaked and are expected to rise to
as much as five percent by the end of
the year our business and economics
correspondent gerprit nawan has this
report
lunch
now the most important meal of the day
this school in Plymouth has hungry
mouths to feed and it's harder than ever
more free School meals are coming
through and than we had previously so I
guess that's a cost of living it's
um having a big impact on parents
inflation may be coming down but food
prices are unrelenting they jumped by
another 19 in the year to March it's
enough to put anyone off their food it's
now very difficult to continue to
provide the quality and meet all of the
school food standards that were acquired
to meet every single day we've removed
beef from our menus because it's too
expensive so we we've stopped buying
from Cornish Farms to do that and we've
used more chicken and we use more Gammon
but even so the cost of those products
through animal feed affected by the war
in Ukraine have increased his worries
have been heard 200 miles away in
Westminster where policymakers are
desperately trying to get a grip on the
problem this is a small headline fall
but it disguises a large rise in food
inflation and it shows that there is no
such thing as an automatic fall in the
headline rate of inflation that's why we
have a plan and if we're going to reduce
that pressure on families it's
absolutely essential that we stick to
that plan and we see it through so that
we halve inflation this year as the
Prime Minister has promised
tasked with bringing inflation down and
it will now have to turn things up a
notch just a few days ago the Outlook
was brighter but it's now almost certain
that the bank of England will have to
raise interest rates again next month in
order to combat inflation
but this medicine comes with pain of its
own and no one knows that better than
the millions of homeowners who could see
their monthly mortgage payments go up
again
so an unpalatable tonic for an
unpalatable problem that just won't
quite go away
no one Sky News
so high inflation is proving to be a
much tougher problem to solve than even
the bank of England may have expected a
business correspondent Paul Kelso has
this assessment of the reasons why it's
proving so hard to sort
every Economist expects inflation to
fall this year but the dissent is
proving stubbornly slow last month the
Consumer Price Index measure of
inflation did come down but it's still
in double digits at 10.1 driven largely
by food prices in food inflation running
at record
19.1 in March remember this is just the
average some Staples have gone up much
much more now these figures are bad news
at home but they're poor by
International standards too average
inflation the euro is only 6.9 in the US
five percent in Japan
3.3 we've already said food is a major
driver of this and this chart shows our
Reliance on Imports compared to the EU
in the middle column here and the US in
the dark blue here they're from before
the pandemic but you can see the UK is
way more dependent on Imports of oil
sugar and dairy products transport and
shipping costs go up as a result and
there's a brexit impact here too it's
added friction and cost to supply chains
then we have energy this chart shows the
domestic energy price Gap over the last
few years you can see the really big
leap in prices was between April 2021
and a year later after the start of the
Ukraine war that's an increase of almost
50 percent there now with government
support the rise in the year since then
has been much smaller around 25 because
inflation is an annual measure that
should drive the official figure down
but not till next month finally we have
the labor market wage inflation was
running at 5.9 percent in the three
months to February it's less than the
overall inflation figure the blue line
here and that means real wages are
actually falling but it also shows
employers are paying more to retain and
recruit staff because the workforce is
smaller than pre-pandemic there are more
than a million unfilled vacancies as
employers struggle to find workers not
helped Again by brexit now energy and
food prices will always fluctuate but
this is the sort of persistent domestic
inflation will worry the chancellor and
the bank of England inflation should
still fall in the coming months but
there'll be cold comfort for consumers
prices won't be coming down they just
won't be going up quite as fast
one of the S P's most senior figures
told Sky News today that her party needs
to get its house in order that looks
even more distant tonight after the
resignation of its Treasurer Colin
Beatty who'd been accused as part of a
police investigation into the party's
finances said he quit to avoid
distraction the question across Scottish
politics now is where the former first
Minister Nicholas sturgeon could face
questions next as Connor Guinness
reports
through all these evidence sessions the
one thing that's concerned me has been
the money
follow the money Colin BT is a veteran
Scottish nationalist a man who's been in
charge of the smp's finances for most of
the past two decades
the party's Treasurer seen here on
Monday after being arrested detained by
detectives investigating finances of
Scotland's biggest political machine now
his resignation from the role he noted
it has not been easy but it is the right
decision to avoid further distraction
from the important work being led by
Hamza Yusuf he said to improve the smp's
governance and transparency
the new SMP regime is paralyzed by
Scandal something recognized by Hamza
yusuf's Deputy the party has to get
tickets what the public would expect the
public would also expect as though as a
government to tackle the issues of
importance to them not least the cost of
living crisis it probably goes beyond
Nicola sturgeon in terms of perhaps a
culture that has been allowed to develop
headquarters and in terms of the
governance of the party a culture
created at SMP headquarters Peter Morrow
was until recently the snp's chief
executive arrested then released by
police as part of the same probe he's
married to Nicholas sturgeon she too
suddenly quit this year later insisting
she will cooperate with police if
requested Colin Beatty began overseeing
SMP financial matters in 2004. he was
replaced briefly in 2020 but his
successor quit in a row over information
not being freely available Colin Beatty
then returned and Hamza Yusuf a close
Ally of the sturgeon era seen as the
continuity candidate with she stood down
this Scandal leaves the SNP in an even
deeper hole it is now without a
permanent chief executive and has an
unexpected vacancy for the role of
Treasurer all the while the party
doesn't have Auditors looking after its
Financial accounts after the last firm
resigned and the police investigation is
intensifying the toughest job in
politics at the beginning of a
Premiership already mired in Scandal
Conor Gillis Sky News Edinburgh
Northern Ireland can never go back to
the violence of the past the Prime
Minister told the dinner of political
leaders past and present tonight Rishi
sunak was speaking as the events to Mark
the 25th anniversary of the Good Friday
agreement come to an end but there is a
very current political problem for him
and the others to solve how to restore
power sharing as our political editor
Beth Rigby reports
the Great and the good together today to
commemorate the long path to peace is
this a moment to celebrate prime
minister
leaders gather in to Mark a deal struck
25 years ago Madam president your
message to the dup bringing peace but
not political stability Northern
Ireland's assembly still stored now of
course we meet here today in
circumstances that are far from perfect
we must keep working to persuade all
parts of the community that returning to
the institutions is the best path
and we will do that Northern Ireland's
Secretary of State confident stormland
will be backed by the year end yeah I'm
a glass half full guy and yes I truly
believe that and I actually believe that
their leadership would love that to
happen too but I think there's a process
to take the whole unionist Community
with them which is vitally important for
peace and stability and prosperity
moving forward
early evening and political leaders of
then and now gathering for a Gala dinner
at Hillsborough Castle to celebrate this
anniversary and consider what comes next
if there is one message from this Hall
tonight one message from the people of
Northern Ireland to the world it is
surely this we will never go back
instead instead we will learn the
lessons of 25 years ago we will keep
working keep moving forward bringing
everyone with us 25 years ago
this
agreement only happened
because
leaders were prepared to put their
leadership in Peril for the good of
their people inside Hills for Castle
tonight The Architects of the Good
Friday agreement and its beneficiaries
commemorate an historic deal that
brought last in peace to Northern
Ireland but even as past political
leaders celebrate their achievements the
current crop are acutely aware that they
are not delivering for people here with
power sharing at storm and still stalled
and no solution in sight the labor
leader urging the PM to help hasten the
restoration of power over here the
government has not played that honest
broker role in the way that I think they
should have done now obviously the
protocol is a step in the right
direction we supported it and voted for
it and I hope that that window of
opportunity to get the institutions back
up is there but it will be a matter for
the parties here in Northern Ireland the
role of the UK government is to be that
honest broker those who brokered the
deal now look to their successors to
protect that Legacy the first step is
getting storm at working again the
harder Journey will be keeping it that
way
quite an image that Beth the Grandy's
out in force with a pretty unified
message that politics in Northern
Ireland needs to restart how much hope
is there that it can
well Anna tonight at that Scarlet dinner
Tony Blair and some of you might
remember it talked about that moment
when he brokered the deal or helped
broker at 25 years ago and said he felt
the hand of history on his shoulder At
The Gala dinner tonight he said
fortunately the hand of history is very
firmly on someone else's shoulder and I
can tell you that politicians are
palpably feeling that pressure the
pressure of storm be installed for the
dup they've really been under Fire from
all sides this week as politicians past
and present urged them to go back to
storm and Chris Heaton Harris with that
critical attack really saying a true
leader knows when to say yes something
Sir Jeffrey Donaldson of the dep didn't
like very much at all Bill Clinton today
telling the dup The Winds of freight
we're at the renegotiated brexit deal uh
that Rishi sunak brokered telling them
that that was the best thing that they
were going to get and for the British
government of course they are under
pressure to try and unlock the dup what
can they give them will there be
increased Financial incentives in the
coming weeks and months what other
assurances can they give them around
trading to try and get them back to the
table but I have to say too that
although there is an impasse the mood
music is positive when I spoke to Chris
Heaton Harris earlier he told me he
believes storm would be up and running
by the end of the year when I spoke to
Doug Beatty the leader of the Ulster
unions he says he knows that Sir Jeffrey
Donaldson wants to come back to storm
and he said he doesn't think that power
sharing will be restored this awesome he
knows it will happen but for the Prime
Minister when he said at that Gala
dinner tonight we won't go back the big
question is how does he move it forward
lots of sound bites this week but still
no substance of an emerging deal
either in Belfast thank you
two men claiming to be former Russian
mercenaries have admitted killing
civilians and children in Ukraine the
two say they were commanders for the
Russian Wagner group and alleged their
orders came from the very top of the
organization those claims have been
denied by the organization's Chief and
both have since taken back their
confessions Sky's International
correspondent Alex Rossi reports
mercenary group presents itself as an
Elite Force in its propaganda
[Music]
this video is complete with Triumph and
music were filmed in the scarred
landscape of eastern Ukraine but
confessions made by men who claim to be
former commanders to a dissident Russian
human rights organization show a very
different site
decay
videos
in this video ex-convict azamat uldarov
describes in disturbing detail how he
killed children
foreign
the alleged atrocities happened in the
Donetsk region in the cities of solidar
and back moot
in January we saw firsthand what Russian
advances had done to civilian areas
where heavy shelling had destroyed homes
and lives in another video Alexi
savageev reveals he was also ordered to
kill civilians including teenage boys by
the leader of Wagner yevgeni pragosian
seen here in combat gear in another
Wagner video has denied the men's claims
and both have since retracted their
confessions although uldarov has since
told the Human Rights group he was
threatened with violence to withdraw his
statements
thank you
but the alleged war crimes would fit
with a pattern of Russian atrocities
committed across Ukraine it will be
extremely important to analyze those
videos carefully obviously to ensure
that what they're showing is accurate
but we do know that literally wherever
Wagner and Wagner's troops are deployed
we see human rights abuses following and
so these are the very very kinds of
allegations that we see in many cases
places around the world
Ukrainian prosecutors are calling for
further investigations but a chance of
any justice for the victims and their
families remains remote Alex Rossi Sky
News
much of the recent hype over ways to
lose weight and fend off diabetes has
been around the impact of weight loss
drugs like wegov a major study though
has confirmed a much more natural if
difficult way to do it reducing what you
eat to a low calorie diet of soup and
shakes it could save the NHS billions of
pounds a year if adopted as our science
correspondent Thomas Moore reports
Lena lighter and diabetes free Kieran
lost nearly three and a half Stone in a
supervised diet of soups and shakes
containing just 800 calories a day that
was eight years ago and by watching his
weight his blood sugar is still under
control without the need for medication
I suppose for me it was a chance to
reboot so when I went to the doctors and
they mentioned it to me I wasn't in a
good place you know a lot of very much
overweight diet was horrendous
um and I was just in a diamond spiral so
gave me a chance to reboot
a new study shows for the first time
that people with a type 2 form of
diabetes which is closely related to
obesity can permanently reverse the
condition if they lose weight and keep
it off the diet will now be prescribed
by the NHS at a cost of little more than
a thousand pounds
losing weight helps to restore the
normal function of the pancreas
stabilizing blood sugar levels this new
research shows the benefits can be
lifelong keep the weight off and there's
no need for pills and injections
including insulin
four and a half million people in the UK
are thought to be living with type 2
diabetes another 2 million are at risk
every week diabetes results in more than
180 amputations
770 strokes and almost 600 heart attacks
and the NHS spends around 10 billion
pounds a year about 10 percent of its
Budget on treating type 2 diabetes and
its complications
there's so many people who sit at home
and perhaps join the gym after Christmas
begin to go to the gym once or twice a
week and then that quickly diminishes so
what we've got to try to encourage
people is we've got to advertise that
weight loss has the biggest impact on
our lives and I don't think many people
actually appreciate that
losing weight can be tough and a new
appetite suppressing drug is available
on the NHS to people who are clinically
obese for Keith diet alone was enough
and dodging diabetes is all the
motivation he needs to watch the
calories
Thomas More Sky News
so she soon act has declared his wife
shares in a Child Care Agency for the
first time after the latest list of
ministerial interests was published the
prime minister is under investigation
for a possible breach of the MP's code
of conducts by not declaring a conflict
of interest when a key Child Care policy
was announced in the budget number 10
insists he had declared it as a
ministerial interest rather than to the
House of Commons
security officers at Heathrow Airport
are set to walk out for a further eight
days of strike action next month
including the day of the king's
coronation the United union says the
strikes will cause inevitable disruption
and delays for passengers
connection Nations has said that India
will become the most populous country in
the world by the middle of this year
both India and China have populations of
more than 1.4 billion people but U.N
officials expect India to pull ahead in
the next few months if it hasn't already
because of a lower birth rate in China
the violence engulfing Sudan is
continuing tonight after a second
ceasefire collapsed almost immediately
among the infrastructure being targeted
in the battle between the Army and
paramilitaries are hospitals and Sky
News has heard of the impact that is
having in the country's capital and in
the troubled region of Darfur our Africa
correspondent the Israel here has this
report
dreams of another ceasefire dashed
as gunfire rings out in Horton
Sudan's capital is suffocating from the
shock of violence and residents are
fleeing to nearby areas on Mass
as the city's infrastructure crumbles
hospitals across Gordon have shut down
some like the universal Hospital have
been hit by nearby shelling and others
like this one were ambushed by rapid
support forces
staff that were trapped have now fled
their emergency rooms to be with their
families
casualties are being redirected to the
few functioning facilities
we need support we need medical supplies
says one volunteer at umderman teaching
Hospital we've suddenly become surgeons
paramedics whatever is needed and the
casualties are too many to count
you can just hear how frustrated and
overwhelmed he is the things they've
seen over the last few days this is one
of the few hospitals that's remained
open in the capital since fighting
started and they're just overwhelmed 50
of the hospitality is more or less not
functioning either because they were
compared because they lack supplies and
they close all because the staff simply
abandoned the hospital and those that
are functioning are like in field
they're like in a medicine they're like
you know they staff personnel
where hundreds of thousands of people
already depend on Aid a Doctors Without
Borders medical supplies Warehouse has
been ransacked by armed militia men
closely affiliated with the rapid
support forces and in Nyala what's your
capacity in nyal at the moment
there's no capacity who lost the
capacity because of this Looting of your
supplies yes yes exactly so for our
capacity is when we have a means to
assist the population if there is no
means basically we we don't have any
more capacity
the rapid support forces have been
looting facilities and homes
the terror they raged in Darfur now
spread to the streets of the capital
Sky News
finally an ultra marathon runner has run
into the record books for the wrong
reasons is the world's best over extreme
distances running 255 miles over 48
hours but in a relatively poultry
50-mile run from Manchester to Liverpool
she came third but was then revealed to
have traveled part of the distance in a
car Katrina vitotsi has more
her endurance has been tested and proven
across the world but it was a race to
Liverpool that seemingly broke her
yuasha zakshevski is a GP in Scotland
but runs Ultra marathons holding world
records and team GB medals over the
Easter weekend she joined hundreds of
extreme athletes for the Manchester to
Liverpool ultra marathon the race starts
just outside the city center and is a
flat and fast 50 miler GPS tracking data
showed Dr zakshevski starting the run
hitting between 8 and 11 minute miles
before getting to around mile 39
it was at that point in the race as the
runners came into this residential part
of Liverpool that the GPS tracking data
on Dr yowasha started to show something
rather unusual that she completed the
next two miles in around four minutes
that would mean at times running faster
than Usain Bolt organizers say the only
explanation could be that she was in a
car
after taking a car for two and a half
miles the runner rejoined others on the
course completing the remaining nine
miles or so on foot ending here near
Liverpool's Aintree racecourse where
with the lift she finished third and
accepted a bronze medal on the podium
I think it's a very unusual story I've
heard of I've heard of people being
disorientated
and potentially getting lost and running
a few more miles than they expected
however I think that as you come towards
the end of the Run typically you know
that if you've had Aid on that run
you've either abandoned or you're going
to elect not to meddle in an interview
with BBC Scotland Dr zakshevski said
she'd felt sick and got a lift to an aid
Point intending to quit but there was
encouraged to finish the race although
in a non-competitive way we put these
comments to organizers who told us after
the event there was no attempt bioasha
to make us aware of what had happened
and to give us an opportunity to correct
the results or return the third place
trophy during the course of the
subsequent seven days the bronze medal
has now gone to the fourth placed Runner
a podiatrist from Yorkshire who wrote on
social media great news for me but
really bad news for sportsmanship
Sky News
well that was good news at 10 coming up
we'll take a first look at tomorrow's
newspapers in the Press preview
including this story on the front page
of the Guardian which says senior
Ministry of Justice officials are ready
to quit if the Deputy Prime Minister
Dominic Robb survives his bullying
inquiry but tonight we're joined by The
Daily Mail columnist Sarah Vine and the
associate editor of the Daily Mirror Kev
Maguire
[Music]
thank you